ban
[音楽]
はいバウンスて労組販売バザーの分
あるまいディバイスアルマン間取図
歩く別種でチョプラで北海道を燃やすなったらそらー
after なぜ by the んだよ70分スライドプラでそこまだ船こうしたが
素材武器をし嘘だぞ
びっくりしましたかはぁ
今アゼルバイジャン語で自己紹介したんです
もちろんそこ桑水流バイザーの宣伝をしたいし大切です
しかし今日はアゼルバイジャンの話をしに来たわけではありません
今日皆さんに伝えたいことがありましてここで話しています
私は今年でですね約5年日本にいることになりまして
ん
現在は北海道大学のスラブユーラシア研究センターで北方領土問題や
アゼルバイジャンと林コクのあるメディアが抱える
まゴールのからば紛争について研究をしています
今や私の研究は多くの日本の新聞で取り上げられています
またアゼルバイザーのメディアからは
日本の専門家として毎週のように取材の依頼がきます
さらに学生でありながらもあぜるバイザーの特産品の一つであるハチミツを日本の
ビジネスマンの援助をして初めて海外に輸出することに年間連続で成功しています
驚くべきことにその輸出先はここ日本です
ここまでの話を聞くと数学成功している学生だなと思うでしょ
私自身も昔想像することができなかった
自分の理想の姿に近づいているという自信があります
しかし10年前の私はというと今とはまったく違いました
今ほど精神的に強くもなかったし
日本語はおろか英語ですら全く喋れなかったです
今これだけ日本語を話しているのがびっくりするでしょ
当時アゼルバイジャン語で女の子に告白すらできなかったですよ
またですね今から10年前というと学部2年の頃になりますが
当時
つらいことも出来事もを重なりました
性格の府立により私の母と父が別居するようになりました
家族の経済状況もとても苦しいものでした
また当時私は誰より前していた初恋に振られました
彼女のお父さんが他の男性度結婚させたのです
勉学も安定してなかったです
成績もそれほど良くなかったせいか日本から派遣されました
女性の先生にももう一されていました
さらにもっと昔ね今から中45年前に遡ると高校時代ですね
高校の英語の先生に皆の前でいじめられたり
ないがしろにされたり
相手にしてもらえないということもよくありました
当時40代の英語の先生でしたが私は高い点数を取り
爆動くず大学東洋学部日本語学科に入った時もあゆべえは英語ですができないから
日本語はどうせ無理だと言ってました
しかしそんな自分が今皆さん前にこのような素晴らしい舞台で打っ
adobe バージョンまでは日本語を使って自分の成功体験について話しています
それでは私はどのようにして
ダメな自分
ダメな学生から
いろんなことができる今の自分になったのでしょうか
そこが皆さんは一番気にしている
気になるところだと思いますがその話に入る前にまずは自分の根本的な考え方について
皆さんに共有しておきたいと思います
それは人間は誰でもどんな人でも必ず強い地震の核となるものを持っているということ
です
自分にも何かが必ずできることがあると言う
不思議と確信めいた自身の角の元となるものです
自分には必ず何かができるとやれると思いながらも不安に買われるのは
その過去を見つけられていないからです
自分の本当の強みを掘り当てていないからです
10年前の私もまさにそうでした
自分には必ず何かができるやれることがあるという確信めいた強い地震のもととなる各
があったもののそれが明確ではなかったのでまずは小さなことから始めようと思いまし
た
学部2年の後期になると毎週木曜部日本人の先生が行なっていた
日本語のテスト2真剣に取り組む努力をすることにしました
それまでにテスト自体をよくサボったりクラスの中でも一番低い点数成績をとって
ずっと下の方にいたんですけどね
それが
努力し続けた結果年間で初めて
みんなより高い点数成績を取り取ることができました
これはあの当時のそのテストの結果ですね
で自分もやればできるという思いはこうやって小さな地震に変わりました
また3年生になると漢字の勉強に集中しました
周りから周囲から歩く辞書というニックネームを付けられるほどになりました
アゼルバイジャンに日本の方が訪れるといううちの大学にも来てくれました
そこで日本人も書けないという漢字も書け
みんな空一面を置かれるようになりました
こうやって自分も
たくさんですね小さなに成功経験を積み上げてきました
しかしここで壁にぶつかったのです
2008年になると
azul by 山にある日本大使館で
日本一年間奨学金で留学できるための試験があり私も含めてみんなで
頑張ってその試験で望んでました
結果として私の不合格となりました
あんなにも漢字の勉強したのに
なんで日本語がうまくならないだろうと
プレスも違いましたし落ち込みもしました
そのそうか月号
膜にある日本大使館で開催された会話クラブの後当時日本語を教えてくれていた
私の恩師でも渡辺先生と一緒に帰りました
途中で渡辺先生の放った強烈な言葉により
私の日本語レベル8テーマが大きく変わりました
先生は次の言葉おっしゃってくれたのです
針レイさんは漢字や日本語の文法
合意の勉強に熱心です誰よりもよく知っています
これは評価できますしかしあれば会三次会して欲しいのは彼らは食事というところの
痛みに過ぎないものです
春べえさんは今現在ビタミンばっかり飲んでますそれも大切ですが
主なメインの食事も食べてくださいと
とにかく日本語の本小説作品新聞をたくさん読んで読解能力上げてくださいと
また日本人と積極的に会話して自分のスペース能力を上げていってくださいという
こんなのがよくあるアドバイスだな当たり前だろうと思う方もいらっしゃるかもしれ
ません
しかし渡辺先生は日本語の合意
文法感じがやってない学生に対してそういう発言したでしょうか
また
漢字は文法を合意を勉強してない学生は渡辺先生がおっしゃったことを理解できた
でしょうか
私はある一定以上日本語の文法
漢字や語彙勉強しただからこそ理解できていたからこそ
渡辺先生がおっしゃったことが私にとって響き
視野が広がり新たなものが見えまた
乗り越えるべきものがあなたに定まったのです
渡辺先生のアドバイスいただいてから私は
合意や漢字文法だけじゃなく
日本語の読解能力やスピーチ能力を上げていくためにアゼルバイジャンにある
日本大使館図書館によく通い
日本語の本や新聞たくさん読むようになりました
また箱に住んでいる日本人と関係者と仲良くできるようになりました
このようにして自分の読解能力や
スピーチ能力を上げてきました
しかしまたここで
別の壁にも使いました
私は軍海に派遣されることになったのです
アゼルバイジャンは徴兵制で健康のところはみんな軍隊に行かなければなりません
慰安すると逮捕されてしまいます
私はこの期間全く日本語の勉強することで出来ませんでしょうん
やはり2010年に軍隊から帰ってくると私の日本語能力がサビつき
もうある米は復活できないもうあいべにも無理だと言う
噂がまた広がり始めました
しかし私には誰にも負けないという自信がありました
私には強い書くとそれまでの日本語の学習で
エター
できることとそれに付随する自信というものが私を支え
駆り立ててくれていたからです
私は絶対自分には何かができると思いました
自分の中で何かがいつも燃えてました
私は勉強を再開しました渡辺先生がご指摘されました
読解能力や州ペイジ能力日かで出てきました
箱に住んでいる日本人とできる限りでは洋高の関係を築きました
そして1年後に大使館で行われる試験で臨みました
試験は2つあり双方の試験で合格しました
日本語の勉強を始めて以来初となる日本上陸が可能となりました
最高に気持ちがよかったです
私は
今までですねこうやって周囲に無理だと言われたり口家そうになった時にも常に
自分の確信めいた自分の自信の角のもととなるようなものを持っていました
一つ一つ壁を乗り越えるとその確信めいたものが自身に変わりました
その自身でまた一つ壁を乗り越えると
そうやって自分のできる幅が広がります深みが増します
それによってまた挑戦したいことまた
乗り越えなくてはいけないものが出てきます
自分自身とできることを乗り越えます
このようにして自分が見える世界が世界の幅がまた広がり深みが増します
私のこれまでの人生はこの繰り返しでした
私は
確信めいた自分の自信の角の元となるものが後から得られるものではなく
その人の
中にもともと備わっているものだと思います
本来できることに気付き認めてあげるそれこそが自身です
私の場合は自身の最初のきっかけは日本語の小テストでした
日本語の小テストができることに自分が木槌
認めました
そうして自分がしたいやりたいことに対して自分の自分への制限や抑制や自然と外れて
きました
皆さんもそれと同様で皆さんの前になる
妬みも
そうで自然とほぐれていきます
azul by 山にはこういう言葉があります
行ってきぺキが湖となり
流れ流れ洪水になる
ダンまだんがアフ
ダンまだも魚道が赤がセローどうぞ日本語で言うところの
塵も積もれば
山となるですね
まさに自分の可能性自分のできること自分自身を広げていく言葉
このことだと思います
ただ私はこのことわざはこれで終わりだと思っていません
洪水のように勢いのある水が
やがてん
海やと流れ月
もっと深いもっと広い無限の可能性のある
世界が見渡す限り広がります
進めば進むほど自分の元いた世界と
まったく異なるものになるかもしれません
1件海を
進んでいくことは
深野ぷかと思う方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
しかし私はその身を超えることができたからこそこうして日本に渡り
皆さんの前でこうして話
今目の前にこうして新たな世界が見えます
なんてワクワクする世界でしょう
皆さんにとってもこの言葉ぞのように行ってき定期を集めていることは
決してあなたたち悪いことではないかもしれません
どうですか
日本語小テストのようにまずは小さなことから始めてみませんか
静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]